oubliée la fashion week si je te parle
de la famille royale d'aldo vie
qu'est-ce que ça t'évoque et bien je
sais que le roi est mort l'an dernier et
que le prince se faisait reprendre ses
fonctions est instable et un mondain à
la vie sulfureuse pourquoi moi tu as du
talent de l'ambition plus intelligente
et tout le monde est booké la semaine
prochaine malheureusement
si tu réussis ce reportage ça va
propulser ta carrière
c'est ça oui je suis à l'intérieur du
palais
c'est mieux qu'une interview exclusive
fait un maximum de vidéos de photos
réuni un maximum
[Musique]
bonsoir on y va tu vas voir
vous avez l'air totalement fasciné par
mon frère
la rumeur prétend aussi que vous ne
voulez pas renoncer à votre mode de vie
c'est quoi mon mode de vie que je sais
pas peut-être les femmes du vin et la
musique
alors c'est comme ça que vous imaginez
je ne connais pas grand chose de vous
en tout cas j'espère que vous serez là
demain soir demain soir oui au bal du
réveillon qu'est ce que c'est leur
mission faire de douanne be
[Musique]
on peut savoir ce que tu attends
la regarde parce que vous êtes
magnifique
roy peut se sentir très seul vous avez
il n'a pas sa reine
[Musique]